you will not hire anyone from Harvard
until the school's Deans step down I
think a lot of leaders have to do it it
was disgusting what those uh Deans and
presidents did under oath uh makes no
sense to me I don't know how if you
can't condemn genocide I don't care
whether we're talking Jews Muslims any
group of people then you don't deserve
to be you know in a position of power
you got to get out ladies and gentlemen
of today's show if you don't back down
if you do the right thing for the right
thing sake you might actually for change
for good how do I know it well Liz
McGill from upen has resigned yes that's
right I don't need to read the whole
thing to you but after that absolutely
horrific Congressional hearing where she
could not condemn calling for genocide
of Jews and again as Porto points out it
wouldn't matter if you were calling for
genocide of Muslims if you're calling
for genocide of white people that would
be just as bad